again him forbes content just
once no idea what did I do there
so much schiller
yes that is a very solid build up of
course for black
so
he stands there a bit strange but
if the idea was now
to bring the jumpers here actively then
yes me  would like to put it after the four
can't be a bad plan
okay because the time here take
it so now of course but it's
somehow
springer no
better quote yourself the direction then
right after the 6
yes the figures so a bit of a ball
is
right now the village is everything  not
true then black
he is fixed now but
actively he can not do much
tries but what time
yes he just played his stuff down
and just ignores what I do
well let's go one
like that
yes
it wasn't clear how white is
here live now
you also have to say
she doesn't he just brings the 6 there too
yes okay we have to see if
I might have a little more a  The other
way of proceeding is of course not
much going
on without India now had the idea maybe a
king has two and loosely has three
runners one becomes aware of the 2
yes he has he clear I cannot
prevent that I have to yes and take
it ok so I am  I'll go now
and night watchman also the 2 he
has himself as a half 11 3 that
makes the springer still
movable
exchange exchange thousands of course he
would like to exchange everything yes but
exchange everything everything that also through now
so the area from
well that  it's just right now
you can turn yourself upside down
yes now maybe
do my trick yes there with 354
well always here from
originally I was
a bit uncomfortable anyway
I just didn't feel anything well well so
maybe you stand even
worse  I don't know either
but now really nothing at all
so yes yes come on I always thought that
well I don't know but at least that
gives the position
a bite  chen imbalance after the
pawns okay
so
if he gives me a lot of time now
then maybe
i can try something again on the women's
wing
yes i want a position like that now he
can't play well with
six the beans i can't
move much  I
would like to run up and swap everyone
that he has to be able to beforehand well
plays b6 then I have the forks
here check the pawn
yes what he pressed out of stone
yes of course
can't see it here
mateja better prevents the counterplay
yes stupid
but
that should now  a bit don't
build his to win me maybe a
bag full of part-time help which
could even win
yes he is through actually yes
no idea was of course
anyway somehow not the same
position until he hired the farmer
but that was always so very clear
afterwards  how much allowed